herr komplette zerstörung häuserruinen
wir fahren mit ihnen durch mario pohl
denn hier sieht man ganz klar putin will
die stadt und seine menschen aus hungern
heute ein verzweifelter hilferuf aus der
stadt mariupol ruf zur vollständigen
evakuierung auf die menschen dort sie
müssen raus ist ruhe eine humanitäre
katastrophe
160000 seien ohne strom busse stehen
bereit aber russland habe keine freie
passage zugesagt wir haben mit dem vize
bürgermeister der stadt mit sergej orlow
gesprochen
[Musik]
mario pohl einst eine schillernde
ukrainische metropole am asowschen meer
heute in schutt und asche hier zeigt
russland was es am besten kann
zerstören
[Musik]
bis sie die den momenten im moment ist
völlig zerstört durch russische truppen
es ist für ihn die frei findet sich
unter vollständiger blockade seit mehr
als 25 tagen und russland lässt es
wären probleme zu lösen ist kein laster
keine nahrungsmittel keine
medikamente keine heizung noch keine
elektrizität die menschen versuchen
irgendwie zu überleben
wird ständig die stadt unter ständigem
artilleriebeschuss
es wird aus der luft
bombardiert vor sieben tagen
unsere zivile infrastruktur von see her
zu stirbt verstörend aus der luft
unbegreiflich die bilder der zerstörung
russland schreckt vor nichts zurück
sogar kinder werden gezielt angegriffen
wie in diesem theater auf dem vorplatz
steht gut sichtbar zu lesen die kinder
hier suchten menschen schutz doch das
ist dem nachbarland völlig egal eine
bombe das theater
vernichtet
meine herr mein herz und meine seele
sind rohren ich kann gefühlen es ihm
nicht mit worten beschreiben wie wir uns
fühlen wenn wir diese fürchterlichen
zerstörungen sehen wenn wir von
todesfällen erfahren und all diese
zerstörung sehen die putin angerichtet
hat in mariupol aber das schlimmste ist
dass wir nicht helfen können so wie wir
das gerne tun
würden
mario pohl ist strategisch wichtig für
putin und seine anhänger sie ist das
letzte hindernis um eine landbrücke zur
bereits annektierten krim zu schlagen
die stadt und dessen anwohner stehen den
russen dabei im weg wir sind absolut
überzeugt dass russland nichts wieder
aufbauen wird keine grad die häuser
keine kindergärten wollen einfach alles
zerstören und so wie viele wie möglich
ukraine
umbringen aktuell befinden sich noch
circa 200.000 menschen in der stadt doch
lieben kann man das nicht mehr nennen
wenn menschen leben und wohnen auf der
erde auf dem boden liegen unterstände
nirgendwo
irgendwo unter der erde
leben wie böse und versuchen irgendwie
zu überleben
[Musik]